Donald Trump is once again trying to
collude with a foreign power to win an
election this time it's 2020 with
Ukraine against Joe Biden it sort of
sounds like that board game Clue it's
Trump in 2020 with Ukraine against Joe
Biden and we knew that Trump was willing
to do this because he told us several
months ago when he was interviewed by
George Stephanopoulos on in ABC that if
a foreign power came to him offering
help in 2020 he would accept it sure he
would look at the info he would look at
what they had and as shocking as that
was after everything that has happened
this is actually worse because this is
more than trying to collude this is you
could call it bribery you could call it
extortion and even those terms don't
really cover it because Donald Trump is
withholding 250 million dollars in aid
from Ukraine because they are apparently
unwilling to smear Joe Biden and his son
Donald Trump directed Rudy Giuliani to
pressure the Ukrainian president to
investigate Joe Biden's son to try to
hurt Joe Biden and the new part is what
we are now learning that the White House
has actually been playing games with
this suspending delivery of 250 million
in military aid to Ukraine and also
refusing an in-person White House visit
to the Ukrainian president and there's a
report now that during a phone call back
in July Donald Trump asked the Ukrainian
president eight times to investigate the
son of Joe Biden specifically saying
work with Rudy Giuliani in order to do
it we have video of Rudy coming up later
in the show on this I asked whether he
discussed Biden in conversation with the
Ukrainian president Donald Trump said it
doesn't matter what I discussed which is
of course a complete non denial because
the reports are accurate and we actually
will have video of crumpled later in the
show saying that the topic of Biden did
come up during that conversation
although he didn't give the specifics
the word traitor is more present and
reasonable in this conversation than it
has ever been before the unlimited
willingness to just abuse power in ways
that undermine
national security and go against
everything that this country is supposed
to stand for and the words bribery and
extortion apply here colloquially but
this is actually much worse Renato
Mariotti wrote a really good piece in
Politico he's been a guest on the show
that bribery and extortion don't even
really account for what Donald Trump has
done here Mariotti says that these
panels with the lawyers on TV arguing
about is this or isn't criminal bribery
or are the charges bogus Mariotti
explains that what Donald Trump is doing
here is actually so bad and so immoral
and so unamerican and so beyond what the
criminal code is even equipped to handle
that the criminal statutes we have
around bribery and extortion likely
wouldn't even cover what Donald Trump
has done here by withholding aid in
exchange for a smear campaign meant to
help him defeat Joe Biden in 2020 and I
don't want you to misunderstand what I'm
saying this is bribery this is extortion
this is potentially traitorous but this
is happening in a way that is so beyond
the scope of what our justice system can
handle that if Donald Trump is charged
with those crimes he would likely not be
convicted can Democrats get it together
and find a way to hold Donald Trump
accountable and make something happen
does Ukraine have the call recorded and
can they release it so we can figure out
what was said and then there's the
additional element here which is
stunning which is that this all may have
been copped to by the White House the
White House may have even been involved
in leaking this or admitting after the
fact that this took place because the
truth of the situation may be even worse
and what I mean by that is the White
House may have calculated that it being
known that 250 million dollars are being
withheld because Trump wants Ukraine to
smear Biden that may not be as bad as
the full scope of what it is that has
actually a transpired here and whether
we will ever know the full scope as
usual as a question mark whether there
will be any consequence
the trend has been that for this
administration there are no consequences
so I'm sticking with there probably
won't be after the break we will have
video of Rudy Giuliani denying and then
immediately admitting that this is
something they are doing we will have
video of a visibly red and disheveled
Donald Trump not denying that this is
what is going on a lot of stunning video
coming up after the break make sure that
you're following the David Pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show and if
you want to see my first pepper I've got
a pepper plant I harvest it isn't this
exciting I harvested my first pepper
this morning and posted a video to my
Instagram at David Pakman follow me
there we'll be right we'll be back right
after this with extraordinarily
confusing and disturbing video I want to
tell you about one of our sponsors
called the Menlo Club immense fashion
community that provides carefully
curated style packages for any type of
guy and they're giving you as a David
Pakman show viewer your first box for
$35 off when you click the link
underneath this video or go to their
site and use the promo code Pakman as a
member of the Menlo Club you receive
delivered right to your door a
hand-picked apparel package that follows
the seasons latest trends based on your
own unique style profile I hate shopping
for clothes it's always been a pain to
go to a store figure out what to buy and
that's why the Menlo Club is so perfect
for me all I had to do was fill out a
quiz on their website so they could
learn my sizes and style preferences and
then I received clothes that perfectly
fit my own personal style so far I've
really enjoyed what they've sent me all
of their clothing is designed by their
team in Los Angeles
each box features items from their own
in-house fashion brands 5 for everyday
wear New Republic Footwear and Grande
see athleisure wear in every box they
send you you get a minimum of two items
often more every box is different
shipping is always free and they let you
exchange what you get if it doesn't fit
you can pause or cancel your
subscription at any time right now I am
on their monthly subscription for 60
bucks a month but they also offer a
seasonal subscription where they send
you a box of clothing every three months
for just 75 bucks but regardless of
which option you choose they are giving
everyone in our audience $35 off their
first box to redeem your $35 discount
just click the link under this video or
go to their website and use the promo
code Pakman at checkout